so when you carry the saw it off what
was the what was the reason for that
versus you know where are you going that
night I'm glad you asked that because we
I used to call it saw it off Sundays
so on sawed off Sundays we would all
take our sawed off shotguns and back in
those days the party Crews would throw
these parties and we thought this party
was safe and it was all bad I just see a
rifle come out
and my [__] one of my friends I'm not
gonna say his name or [__] but this
[__] poor kid's only 15 14 years old
and he's [__] with the business pulls
his [__] out and just starts dumping
boom boom I'm talking like
people are like this is how it's like
like I've never heard this kind of gun
before
and like how you said like when it hits
brick yeah all the pieces because we
don't know how to [__] shoot though
we're missing everything
like I remember pulling my bandana up
what the [__]